b5 was played h6 check
our last moves josh has to uh pardon me
josh
sam has to move his king i'm expecting
him he ate already king g8
yeah just to move you the king away from
any dark square
right and what uh sam has in mind
is playing queen takes f1 check
then promoting his pawn to a queen and
then with his new queen just
coming back to d4 queen defensive on
that diagonal
covering all the dark squares right
exactly
and instead of probably josh if he's
going to try to continue
playing here oh you think he's going to
play h7 oh well i don't know do you
think he has
a second choice queen f6
uh runs into precisely that line of play
that
we just um and he has blade h7 jack
exactly because once the queen comes
back here on d4
you you protect uh the key g7 square no
checkmates
and um well well black's just a rook in
the night ahead
sam instantly played king g7 right the
fun the fun thing about sam is that when
it seems when he's winning he just plays
instantly
well and actually i kind of like that i
mean
it's fun yeah well i mean you know he's
got it down he sees the
he's he sees the cold wind let me get
out of here yeah i mean yeah
let's uh let's wrap this thing up
players who are winning they still write
down them you know they they look they
write it down slowly or move they think
about
it right even if they know exactly what
they're gonna play they just kind of
have this custom
to think 10-20 seconds right or five
whatever
right he's just like bang let's get on
with business uh
in the case of uh gary kasparov it was
the watch
uh he he would just after a move like
king g7 now he'd he'd be putting on the
watch and starting to stare at you like
okay uh you've had your lesson time's up
let's get going well i think sam's got
the best glaring in the tournament
actually i mean it's pretty good isn't
it yeah yeah i'm impressed
i mean i've been up against some really
good glarers you know karpov kasparov
michael tall
those guys had good glares by the way
one guy who never glared
anything was vasilis misoff he never
looked at you because i as i realized
later in his career
he was actually going blind so he didn't
have a glare
to glare at you with so that was
but sam's got a good one
uh maurice you have a story to share
just a small tactic a small tactic in
one of the games oh we should get back
to that other game quickly because it
looks like a move was played
a dramatic move i don't want to spoil
this moment uh
he queen h6 now in this game i believe
did you say queen 86 was played i don't
know actually i don't see a move
oh okay but i was thinking that that he
might play queen h6
all right you psyched me out there queen
a6 is indeed possible but it won't last
very long so let me just get back to
this other game i want to show you
what happened here in a game between
onus chuck
who mathematically is out of the
tournament so is nardinski
but ownership was at least playing for
pride and for some money
quite frankly there's dollars at stake
here depending on how you place
and he got this position against
naraditsky he's been up a pawn nursing
the position for quite some time
nardiske managed to trade off queens in
this position
ownership probably felt you know this is
pretty good i'm up a pawn i'm gonna
get my king in and start pushing and
naradiski played this nice move
bishop to a6 a weird move it's like what
are you doing over there
well obviously the point is if the king
decides
to go to the h5 square then suddenly out
of nowhere comes this move
bishop takes on c4 and on a capture
push and how do you stop the past pawn
you're almost
lost it turns out there's one way to
save yourself put the bishop on g8 to
get to h7
but now the move king to g7 stopping
that dream
and when you bring your bishop back to
e6 king back to f6
and this would be a forced repetition
for both sides leading to a draw
so now suddenly
nareditsky is back in business after
this move and he is safe on the board so
it looks like he's going to get a draw
out of this game
and we do have an official result in
malnour lendermen they have shaken hands
we do expect them
to come down and talk to us about their
draw
and see what lendermen saw in that
variation now meanwhile
in josh riddell sam shankland let's see
if josh has any fight left
him at all i was just mentioning this
funny move um queen to h6 check
unfortunately
doesn't uh well for white doesn't amount
to much of course you can't go back to
um to f8 because you can't go back to h8
because
of um well actually in this position
just king to g5 right and it looks like
the king is
is cruising and actually making
um no perpetuals no perpetuals the king
just
uh walks and hides behind
the extra rook uh the trick
there the the one trick that i think you
were about to mention
is you don't want to drop back to age
eight because then after queen
and oh dear and uh the rook on
fs the queen on f7 spears
the uh rook on d5 well instead actually
josh riddell didn't even try that
instead he just played rook to d1
so we'll take a look in a bit how best
shanklin should mop
up in this game but right now we've got
alexander lenderman
still leading the tournament along with
varus nakobian and
we couldn't have hoped for a better
battle tomorrow they will be playing
lenderman will have the white pieces
he's with maurice ashley about his game
today and what's to come thanks jen
we're with grandmaster alexander
lindeman
first of all alex how did you feel about
your game
um i thought maybe i was tiny bit worse
out of the opening but then i thought
uh after e5 i thought i was getting a
good game so i thought
i might be better somewhere but i'm not
sure
i might have missed something but i'm
not sure where well we have a
variation that the computer shows that
you were winning at one point
in the game the moment when you played
the move
e4 after he played c4 we can go just one
step further
uh according to the computer this move
bishop to g4 if you may
press new variation please uh did you
consider this idea of
f3 and e4 yes i did in some lines so
what happens if f takes g4
f takes g4 then queen takes g3 check
aha with the knight on you one right ah
oh wait but so what
oh ah i see the idea now
now that you played c4 okay so if knight
g2
knight takes g4 bishop f4
there's bishop c5 earlier i forgot the
pawn move to c4 there was the rook d4
move earlier and it was unclear
but now that the pawn moved i didn't
catch the difference actually because i
thought
apparently four was also very good i had
some pressure and uh
i was a bit a bit low on time relatively
speaking was a complicated position and
i forgot to look at that idea deeply
again i didn't quite
catch the difference between the pawn on
c3 and the pawn on c4 but
i was i was looking at the idea but i
guess i just didn't find it at the right
moment but
wow so how do you feel about having such
a
beautiful opportunity at seven points it
happens
that's it it's just it is what it is wow
so
here's the battle years of battle you're
sitting on six and a half now tied for
first
with a huge game ahead against your main
rival in the tournament
baruch nakobian what are your thoughts
on that game no it should be an
interesting battle
what's your record against him uh i
think
one and a half out of three have you
ever defeated him in a competition
yeah but i got very lucky in that game
that wasn't fox was you know nine he
i blunted the pawn out of the opening
and then he uh
he just uh somehow i luckily got some
compensation out of nowhere and he just
underestimated it and
i won a nice game after that but i i
don't really count that game very
seriously
so what are your thoughts now you're
you're obviously playing against a very
tough player
and your championship has been
rollercoaster to say the least you
started off
sky high then you dipped real low but
not low enough because then you were
able to come back up again
what are your thoughts now today and
again i missed opportunities so i guess
it's just uh
the whole idea is just to forget what
happened and just battle
back and just do the best you can and
take what you get
you what you can get you know it's it
happened
whatever happened happened you know i'm
not perfect i'm not gonna see
every you know ever everything obviously
i'm human so
i have to just accept that and move on
and play tomorrow as if
nothing happened and with the white
pieces tomorrow will do you think that
you'll be pressing
all the way putting your foot on the gas
for the victory i mean after all it's
the u.s championship at stake a win
wins it all yeah we'll see you know i'll
just have to play play chess i mean i
obviously i i can't ex i i haven't
thought about exactly how i'll play
tomorrow i guess i'll have to discuss it
with my coach
and what are your inclinations i mean
without your coach what's your feeling
about me
no idea right now right now my idea is
to
eat a little but then get some rest and
then think about it
all right well thanks so much
congratulations and hopefully you do
well tomorrow
best of luck thank you grandmaster
alexander lindeman with a win
could be the new u.s champion guys
wow that was great thanks guys i thought
that uh
finding out that what lenderman missed
was the finesse of c4 and c3
which is really interesting right it's
sort of like that bishop c5 check
with the pawn on c3 he saw that the rook
could block
said i'm a piece down i'm going to do
that it's complicated but then suddenly
when this pawn is on c4 there's
no longer that blocking defense and that
subtle
subtle subtle dis difference earlier
he had analyzed and rejected the line
didn't come back to it at the critical
moment
and that's why when you look at
sacrifices and they don't work
it doesn't mean that's a waste of time
no it's a lot of times this is exactly
what happens
right detail the changes in the data in
the position and suddenly
all that uh work comes to something
right it's a recurrence close to what
happened here
yeah like a recurring theme uh suddenly
the opportunity is there again
and we have a result in josh verdell sam
shanklin josh brudeau did try this h86
and h8 queen line but
he did realize after king to g5 that he
was going to run out of checks
and sam was going to mop up and that
puts josh fredell out of contention of
the u.s championship
and sam shanklin continues to earn his
title of spoiler of the century
i'm telling you i mean people are going
to hate sam
after this event i mean one thing's for
sure i mean he should just play in a
tournament where he chases the leader
that's right he needs to start playing
all the leaders exactly
if you think about it guys there's only
one guy in this tournament who likes him
it's gotta come ski
yeah he's the only guy who likes him
because
i mean he has beaten the other three
contenders and god is just like thank
you thank you thank you
what i couldn't do thank you for doing
right so uh
at least kamsky did beat lenderman but
still
this this is incredible what sam has
done just
showing that he's not afraid of anyone
and anybody in the tournament could be a
victim
if they sit across the board from him
that's right although this round of
course
this round bar and lenderman are happy
that now josh
is out of the picture of that potential
playoff which now could lead it could be
a three-way playoff but not a four-way
play-off but i'm telling you i'm not
counting out the defending champion
godokamsky i mean he's a wily veteran
he's been there he's soft-spoken he's
he's
talked about well he's talked down his
own chances in this event
but i got to tell you something if he
was fortunate enough to get himself into
a playoff
boy uh i i'd be betting on him
oh yes definitely i mean even even if he
does
i think that he's a such a fine rapid
player and has so much experience in
these high stakes playoffs
that even if his tie breaks are worse
and he has to win two rapid matches i
might put my money on him i mean it's
that
it's that i mean i mean he's a very good
rapid player and he's played like three
of these armageddon games before
yeah all of that experience counts for a
great deal
and we've got sam uh the spoiler
shankland
in our studio to explain to us why he
only likes to beat up on tournament
leaders
he doesn't have a plus core now yeah
indeed jen
the spoiler that's that's what he's
going to be called not the closer the
spoiler that's a good name no i don't
think he wants
that name that that tag may not be
something i'd rather i'd rather be
fighting for first at some moments which
i've never been in this tournament but
what can you do no but so far you've
played against the tournament leaders
and
spoiled their chances really upset some
people josh friedel today
he looked like he had a very nice
position against you yeah then all of a
sudden it just
flipped and bam he was out of there i
don't think it was all of a sudden i
think i
defended very well i wouldn't be
surprised if he had a forced win at some
moment but i didn't see it and it looked
very promising for him
but um i think uh at some moment i
equalized and then he played bishop to
xb5 which i think was extremely
optimistic
and without that if he plays queen f3 or
something i don't really think errs no
queen f3 hangs the queen no queen f3
doesn't hang the queen
yeah if he plays queen f3 or something
he should be fine i think it's just
equal
but after bishop b5 i think i got the
upper hand
you got the abraham uh pretty
dramatically you're able to take on b2
and suddenly his position fell
yeah well he may have missed after h5
queen b2 hg6 so i can just ignore it and
take the bishop uh
after gf7 check king f7 queen f3 king
easter so nobody's following your
variation but you right now so that's
not good
go too fast but you're saying that he
missed that his bishop was hanging
well probably he missed it well i if i
can take it my king goes for a stroll
but i think he survives it
i probably that's what josh missed i'm
not sure but i think after queen takes
b2 black's probably close to winning
how did you manage your emotions in this
tournament i mean you
had a couple of bad games i mean to say
the least
more than two yeah i mean it just you
must have really been disappointed and
then somehow
you've turned it all around and just
been crushing people it's the mark of a
strong character to come back from
disappointment
and i think that's one of the biggest
things that pushed me from
2400 to 2600 is i mean i i remember
two my first two us championships when i
was like 16 and 17.
i bought i started both just fine and
then i lost a couple games and then just
lost the rest because i couldn't keep
myself under control but now i think i'm
much more sure and
i think it's i mean i remember
aaron berg made a comment about playing
mueller after he lost three games so
he's saying you know probably he should
play for a win because you know he'll be
in a bad spot but i don't think that
will ever work against me that's one of
my biggest strengths
so i'm very happy that i was able to
come back and beat josh who's been
playing amazing chess this tournament
indeed now you can't win the tournament
anymore
playing spoiler is not it's not in the
role now so how do you motivate yourself
for the last game a lot of money
i mean if i win i probably i'm getting a
share of third that's some colossal
amount of money
so uh i mean the probably the prize
money differential between every half
point is at least two and a half
thousand dollars i have
every bit of motivation to fight with
teamwork tomorrow excellent
uh one last comment yeah what do you
think about the game between
the two leaders right now they're at six
and a half yeah the lenderman versus a
kobeyon
who would you put your money on i don't
know i wanna i mean
i like alex but i really don't want him
to win because if he wins i don't go to
the olympiad
but um so you have a rooting interest
here i do
uh that's probably a five six thousand
dollar swing for uh
if he wins this game so i'm gonna really
hope that he doesn't uh
but i think it'll be a good fight but
i i don't think it'll be a draw i think
they'll both understand that if they
draw their game they're going to have to
deal with kamsky and that's going to be
very bad news because
i mean kamsky as he's shown here he's
not been a or not that just goes around
and kills everybody but he's just never
been in danger of losing and
when you have to actually beat him at
some moment to get through a playoff i
think he's a colossal favorite because
he's just too solid and he'll take his
chances
well thanks so much for the interview
good luck in your last game thank you
it's all about the money guys young kid
has his head straight in that
capitalistic mode
make that loop back to you guys
thank you maurice uh so we're wrapping
up today
uh an exciting day one of missed
opportunities for alex lenderman
he could have been the clear tournament
leader draw today
kamsky's still in the mix still in
that the house was absolutely thrilling
yeah barn burners excitement
right turn around this it's kind of just
like we're we're
building attention to the final day do i
say we miss the ladies
we do but i mean the the u.s
championship
yesterday was just thrilling as well
absolutely so
tomorrow the ladies are going to be back
let's take a look at the u.s
championship standings
well in the u.s championship uh we have
the same players at the top
for roose and kobien and lenderman and
they are playing tomorrow
lenderman's getting the white pieces and
for the ladies
we've got irena crush and anna zaponsky
tied at the top they played yesterday
so it'll all be about can they both win
their games and secure a playoff
for the u.s women's chess championship
title
one of the wins in the other doesn't
then that's that's then she's the winner
and also kamsky is hoping for a draw
just as
sam shanklin said he's hoping for a draw
between
um okobian and lenderman
kamsky's hoping for a draw needs a win
against josh friedel
and then bang he's in he's a member of
the playoff
so ah exciting day tomorrow it'll all be
decided
men's and women's incredible yeah i mean
just those two critical games i really
can't wait to see it go down
championship has been
so much more exciting than i think
anyone could have imagined
i thought you know i had a sense of it
actually from the very beginning i was
looking through the lineup all grand
master lineup in the men's
i thought that irina and anna
were going to dominate the women's uh as
they usually do
they didn't disappoint the favorites
there but the favorites and the men's
team morgariev just kind of disappeared
oni onishuk was doing very well but he
also faded
and now you know the young letterman's
saying i'm the new kid on the block
i'm here okovian too maurice we've got a
final word from grandmaster maurice
ashley
well it has been a thrilling competition
some rounds spotty
mistakes in other rounds but that's what
makes for
great entertainment and it has been
entertaining for the most part and it's
good to see that the ladies have the day
off and they come back
and we'll have many games now 11 games
to look at
with tension in some of the games i
don't even know if it's all going to go
down as easily as we thought
because maybe at the top we could see
the two ladies even lose remember that
that candidates where kramnik and magnus
carlson
i would have thought that they would
have lost in the last round of their
competition when they when all was on
the line sometimes attention just gets
to you
and they're taught to have abrahamian if
she wins she could still be in the mix
as well
so definitely lots of possibilities lots
of
potential results something decisive
will happen and take us into a monday
very likely looks like a playoffs jen
you
you said you thought it would be one
with high chances i'm starting to agree
with you as well it seems that that's
the way it's going to go
so a very exciting time now with the
last critical round of the championships
tomorrow
totally agree monday it's going to be
tumultuous with a 70
chance of a playoff that's my call 99
chance i'll be here
yeah and we hope that all of you will
join us tomorrow we know that it's
monday
but make plans this is the what we've
all been waiting for this is what we've
been building up to
the final round of the u.s championship
and the us chess championship
it's here tomorrow at 1 central standard
time to eastern
at the st louis chess club don't miss it
look forward
thank you
what happened in the lebron wrong game
who cares
we're chess people
they are on
sure hey this is jen jihadi
the 2014 u.s chess championships have
not disappointed
version ocobian was expected to do well
and he did
the surprise is alexander lenderman who
knocked off some top contenders to tie
for the lead
they play each other today but not so
fast
defending champion gotta kamsky
if he wins and varusian and alexander
tie
there could be a three-way tie and a
playoff on tuesday
and it all starts now at the 2014 u.s
test championship
let's do that again because i feel like
there's a couple words here
a couple things i i don't know if reason
that kobe wasn't expected to do that
well
it might be an exaggeration he's only a
little bit higher rated than lender and
i mean yeah
uh we could say version of cobian has
been has been an olympiad for the for
the united further
i'm trying to say it tightly like he's
always been like one of the top six
players but he's never really catapulted
into like
championship contention something like
that but tighter
the 2014 u.s chess championships had not
disappointed
farouzi nakobian a perennial olympian
for the
sorry the 2014 u.s chess championships
have not disappointed varus and okobian
always one of the highest ranked players
in the field
but finally he's broken through and he's
playing for the championship
another surprise alexander lenderman
knocked off some of the top contenders
to tie for the lead
they play each other today but not so
fast
if that game is a draw defending
champion godakamsky has a chance
to catch up and create even a three-way
tie
and a playoff on tuesday and it all
starts now at the 2014
u.s chess championships
and it all starts now at the 2014 u.s
chess championships
thank you
you